it's progress on our agenda you know we
believe that our strategy is the right
one but it is a strategy for the very
long term the idea is to be balanced
between a consumer business in a
wholesale business to be balanced
between the UK and the US and a global
platform elsewhere so we like the
diversification of our portfolio of
businesses we like the simplicity and
Barclays UK and Barclays international
so we'd say it's a pretty good year for
us at 16 now you've talked today about
hiring staff in locations such as
Frankfurt and Dublin to try and
future-proof the bank against brexit is
that gonna be at the detriment of London
what I said I think it got a little bit
misinterpreted what I said is we employ
people in Frankfurt today we employ
people in Paris today we employ people
and in in Milan today so we have a
footprint in continental Europe today we
have a very large credit card business
in Hamburg Germany and we have a bank
subsidiary in Ireland so we have a
presence in in in Europe let's see how
the breadth of the brexit negotiations
unfold I think we'll have to make some
tactical shifts depending upon whether
the single market continues or not but
as I've been saying all along
I do believe that London will remain the
principal financial market for Europe
even post brexit but is it fair to say
you'll resigned to the loss of passport
in lights we are looking at
contingencies that will allow us to
continue to continue to do the business
we do today in Europe even if we lose
past boarding right so sure we have to
look at that at that possibility and and
and and invest accordingly why are you
so confident that London is going to
remain the premier destination for
banking within Europe it is very
difficult to replicate in any period of
time the overall ecosystem that you find
in London you know from from from mutual
funds to pension funds to insurance
companies to hedge funds so much of that
if so much of their capital is managed
through a presence in
at Kingdom the legal architecture around
the financial markets that you find in
in the UK it's just very hard to move
that in any period of time and then it's
just a belief that I have that that the
users of capital will find the providers
of capital and that you know the g20 has
been very consistent since the financial
crisis that that they've all agreed that
no one will create barriers to the free
flow of capital that would be you know
that would be a wall that would not
benefit anybody and so it's a belief I
have that at the end of the day there
might be some tactical changes that need
to be made but fundamentally Europe will
not cut itself off from the from the
capital that's available in in the
United Kingdom now I should say one of
the big things that you've done do
you've more or less completed the
restructuring the non-core assets have
been sold off isn't one of the
challenges for you though the underlying
revenue growth is actually lower year on
year is it going to be much harder to
grow this business in the future you
know the number that I would look at is
the core income number for Barclays so
take out the non core business that
we're closing in June the core business
of barkleyz barkleyz UK Barkers
International our credit card business
or retail banking business the wealth
management business all that
collectively revenues or income was
actually up six percent in 2016 versus
2015 that's one of the better
performances of large financial
institutions in the world and I think
underscores that there are a number of
our businesses that have very good
organic growth potential right now so we
actually grew our revenues this year and
we hope that portends the ability to
grow revenues in the next couple of
years now one of the big clouds on the
horizon few still is the fact that
you've got this issue with the US
Justice Department over the mis-selling
of mortgage-backed securities prior to
the financial crisis you more or less
said you'll see them in court
what progress is that report on that
well I think what you saw is we failed
to reach a settlement agreement with
Department of Justice at the end of last
year so they filed their lawsuit against
us this is a long process we have to
file what's called a summary judgment
this will take a quite a bit at a time
so no real prediction on when this will
be resolved one way or another obviously
we would still like to settle this case
with the Department of Justice but it's
we're not going to speculate on
ultimately the timing or nor where or
nor this have or nor how this is
ultimately resolved now clearly it's
been a very good year for your
investment banking division do you
anticipate there being a lot of fear
alrea over bankers bonuses this year you
know for the firt for the third year in
a row our investment banking revenues
were up and our bonus pool and
Investment Banking was down so we
recognize our obligation to our
shareholders and we are managing our
business to try to deliver better
investment performance than we have
previously but we do have to pay
competitively and so we keep an eye on
that but this year whilst our numbers
were good in terms of brought in a lot
in terms of top-line revenue we did
slightly decrease the bonus pool